another Fox News Alert now right now the
House Intelligence Committee is
considering the release of the Democrat
version of last week's Declassified
document alleging abuse of the
surveillance system by political enemies
of the president we're also learning
more about how Associates of Hillary
Clinton may have fed information to the
author of the so-called Trump dossier
chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Herridge is here tonight to
tell us where things stand at this
minute good even Catholic well thank you
but it all comes down to the math the
Democrats will need to flip some
Republicans to secure a majority and get
their version of the memo out of the
committee and on its way to the
president who under long-standing
congressional rules would have five days
to object as a new memo may be in the
offing what we're looking at now is a
State Department and some of the
irregularities there the Republican
chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee said their work is not done
with the focus shifting to foggy bottom
under President Obama what we'll do is
we will follow in phase two we will
follow the facts where they lead and
when we get enough facts we will then
figure out a way to let the American
people know likely it won't be done and
the way that this was done four months
before the presidential election is a
pivotal period by late July 2016 then
FBI director James Comey opened the
Russia Pro and former British spy
Christopher Steele was already sharing
the Trump dossier funded by the DNC and
Clinton campaign with Bureau agents a
former government official under
Secretary Clinton now confirms Steele
also reached out to the State Department
in July 2016 about his findings he
passed two to four pages of short points
of what he was finding and our immediate
reaction to that was this is not in our
purview this needs to go to the FBI if
there is any concern here that one
candidate or the election as a whole
might be influenced by the Russian
Federation Steele is now the subject of
a criminal referral asking the Justice
Department to investigate his handling
of the dossier and whether he lied to
the FBI about its distribution or the
FBI misrepresented his statements the
Republican chairman of the Senate
Judiciary Committee Chuck Grassley along
with Senator Lindsey Graham made the
referral last month and released an
unclassified
fied version while heavily redacted by
the FBI including references to widely
available media reports the senators
wrote another stream of information was
coming to steal quote it is troubling
enough that the Clinton campaign funded
mr. Steele's work but that these Clinton
associates were contemporaneously
feeding mr. Steele allegations raises
additional concerns about his
credibility on Capitol Hill Democrats
led by the House Intelligence Committee
as ranking member who drafted a
competing ten page memo called out
Republicans for rejecting a full
briefing by FBI director Ray well you do
oversight you haul them in under oath
you say why was this included why was
that included the interest wasn't
oversight the interest was a political
hit job on the FBI in the service of the
President the Senate Minority Leader
Chuck Schumer wrote to the president
over the weekend in support of the
Democrats memo and the White House said
it would consider the request under the
same declassification rules that applied
to the Republican version and if we get
an update on that vote Brett will bring
it to you as soon as we get it okay
Katherine thank you